I think what we what we and when I say
we I mean the group of free-thinking
people who want people to co-exist who
don't want to judge people based on all
the identity politics and all that I
would welcome anyone that's watching
this to go back to the we've been on
aura now for two months watch my video
is Sam watch my video with I on watch my
video with majha dan drew and with kara
and whoever it is and see if you'd find
hatred and bigotry in those videos as
really really watch them and see if you
find that Sam's goal really is to nuke
the Middle East because it's Muslims
there or to profile Muslim really see if
what I on who survived genital
mutilation and a forced marriage to a
cousin and her friend being assassinated
on the streets of Amsterdam all in the
name of religion see what she is is the
bigot see if majin who has spent his
life trying to reform who's Muslim who
identifies as Muslim and has tried to
reform his rig and see if he's really
the extremist here if I see if I have
said something that sounds like the real
extremist I talk about peace in the
Middle East I talk about free-thinking
ideas all of these things and apply
those things to you and I think if
people could step back for just a second
they would really realize and you and it
doesn't mean you have to agree with
everything they say you might say well
you know what I still don't like sam
Harris doesn't lay enough blame on the
American industrial complex the
military-industrial complex for X or Y Z
or ion is still more of a neocon than I
might be but those are policy issues
that we all can disagree on right it
doesn't mean that their motives are
based in hatred or whatever these are
true reformers trying to try to apply
the principles that we as liberals
they're trying to have those principles
take root in a part of the world that
these things are totally backwards and
you can argue whether it's all a
religion or its geopolitics or it's all
that we can do that but watch those
videos and go who are the extremists and
guess what it's not us it's not as it's
it's the people that are the extremists
right it's the image to the real
extremists that are chopping people's
heads off and doing horrible things but
then it's also the people
when able them by trying to silence us
exact that is simply the truth